[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
stasera non sono qui per
dirvi che non esiste più un pianeta di
non sono qui per dirvi che le risorse
che stiamo utilizzando adesso sono già
le risorse il prossimo anno non sono
neanche a dirvi qual che il tempo a
nostro favore è ormai sta finendo
non sono qui per
demoralizzarvi sono cerco in qualche
modo di essere stata raccontarvi una
storia la mia storia cercherò di far
vedere solo qualche foto e con l'intento
di farvi tornare a casa un po più
positivi questa storia nasce più o meno
nel 2012 dove mi trovavo in mozambico
paese a me caro dove sono nato e vissuto
e dove in punto mi trovavo per fare un
progetto di cooperazione allo sviluppo
per una ng italiana
ho avuto la fortuna che in quello stesso
medesimo luogo e per i due si trovavano
poi delle persone sarebbero in tanti mi
date per me amici e non solo dei
collaboratori e ci univa la voglia di
cimentarsi in questo mondo della
cooperazione allo sviluppo
chi per studio o chi c'era e nato in
mezzo come sottoscritto ci univa anche
però la volontà di portare avanti e
soprattutto l'idea e tutte le tematiche
relative al climate change al
cambiamento climatico e la natura e
soprattutto come queste non fossero
prese in considerazione nei progetti di
cooperazione allo sviluppo nei paesi in
via di sviluppo perché esattamente nei
paesi mi di sviluppo dove i cambiamenti
climatici stanno dando gli effetti
maggiori si vedono all'ombra si vedono
sotto il sole non sono solo un problema
a livello naturale ma stanno diventando
anche un problema a livello sociale
abbiamo quindi deciso di prendere questi
due argomenti unirli tutti insieme
facendo quindi creando quindi un nuovo
progetto nuovo
un nuovo modo di creare cooperazione
allo sviluppo
basando su dell'azione che potesse in
qualche modo combattere il cammeo change
questa storia quindi nasce con la
volontà di cambiare un po il paradigma
che ci portiamo dietro da rivoluzioni
dustriale più o meno che vede lo
sviluppo economico andare a velocità
elevatissima discapito della natura
vogliamo fare in qualche modo con i
nostri progetti e quello di girare
questa piramide che vede l'uomo in alto
la natura in basso questa storia nasce
anche all'interno di questa storia c'è
anche inevitabilmente come in tante
altre un
inciampo infatti avevamo iniziato con un
progetto forse più grande di noi nel
paese in cui c'è l'ha visto nasce ovvero
mozambico che a un certo punto dopo due
anni di sforzi di intenti di di volontà
a un certo punto s'è interrotto non per
la nostra volontà però purtroppo succede
è stato momento estremamente difficile
stato un momento di estremo
complessità e divisivo fra di noi però
penso che sia stato anche un momento
estremamente importante per la crescita
la nostra personale ma anche del nostro
progetto infatti grazie anche appunto la
volontà del mio socio fondatore michele
non ci siamo arresi abbiamo voluto
quindi darci il tempo e di cambiare
anche quelle che potevano essere nostre
prospettive e cambia la prospettiva
significa cambiare anche il paese di
azione se no siamo quindi trasferiti dal
dall'africa e sun trasferita in un posto
magico che il nord della colombia
esattamente nascere nevada di santa
marta che gli stessi indigeni chiama nel
corso del mondo il cuore del mondo qui
abbiamo cominciato quindi vada ad
approcciarci in un modo diverso
tutte le tematiche principali che girano
la nostra storia che sono il tempo gli
alberi e il coinvolgimento
il tempo significa darci il tempo ovvero
dare il tempo noi di abituarci di
inserirci e quelle che sono le dinamiche
del naturali delle comunità indigene e
locali ma darà anche il tempo le stesse
comunità di accettare la nostra presenza
di darci anche la possibilità di
lavorare con loro il tempo rappresenta
anche un approccio cosa significa
significa che noi ci diamo il tempo di
gestire la natura come la natura vuole
siamo noi che seguiamo la natura siamo
noi che seguiamo quelli che sono in
svolgimento della natura seguiamo quelli
che sono quindi tutti le condizioni
climatiche
seguiamo le piogge liberamente anche di
massima rendita
come si vede nella foto noi ci
distinguiamo anche da altre realtà che
più o meno fanno la che operano su
settore e questo ha a che vedere molto
con il tempo perché noi partiamo sempre
da seme partire dal seme significa dare
alla futura foresta la maggiore
eterogeneità genetica possibile almeno
ci tentiamo il tempo significa anche il
fatto che ci siamo dati più o meno un
anno due anni di tempo appunto per
studiare quelle che sono le specie
arboree
principali del posto in aiuto insieme ai
nostri collaboratori locali che sono
indigeni come cambia dreams ne abbiamo
quindi scelto una dozzina più o meno
ognuna delle quali si contraddistingue
per una caratteristica naturale propria
chi allo sviluppo più alto più veloce
chi ha la maggiore capacità di creare
ombra chi invece la maggiore capacità di
trattenere l'acqua c'è ovvero vogliamo
in questo modo dare la possibilità alla
foresta che verrà che è stata
deforestata di avere tutto intero genta
genetica ma anche di specie che c'era
una volta e l'abbiamo fatto ovviamente
grazie appunto alla all'aiuto delle
comunità indigene che conosceva queste
piante sono piante poi che comunque non
hanno soltanto una funzionalità
arborea la facciamo anche in un concetto
di agroforestry vero sono delle comunque
delle tante che possono avere anche un
approccio alimentare ed economico delle
stesse comunità indigene che collaborano
con noi
come dicevo prima uno dei tre dei tre
principali che a pisa di nostre attività
sono le piante nella natura questo
perché noi quale vogliamo fare è cercare
di creare un circolo economico che passa
attraverso la natura ovvero
combattere il cambiamento climatico come
promotore per uno sviluppo sostenibile
nei paesi in via di sviluppo
quindi cosa facciamo poniamo la pianta
in mezzo un circolo economico che vede
tutti gli interlocutori
all'esterno gli interlocutori sono i
promotori ovvero chi adotta la pianta
che adotta la pianta e poi se ognuno di
voi basta che vada sul nostro sito con
un click molto velocemente adotta una
pianta e poi pensano tutti noi giorgio
referenziato la piantiamo e le facciamo
crescere accudiamo possono essere le
aziende piccole grandi che siano perché
siamo assolutamente convinti che la
lotta cambiamento climatico e deve
essere una lotta comune ma inclusiva
cioè dare quelle che possono essere
degli strumenti facili operativi a tutti
altrimenti
difficilmente riusciremmo a combattere
quelli che sono i cani senti climatici
le piante quindi non rappresentano più
non sono più lasciati
diciamo all'esterno vengono quindi usate
come proprio come metodo di promotore di
un economia
lo facciamo insieme le comunità indigene
e lo facciamo attraverso un processo di
decentralizzazione della figura del
cooperante è una è un metodo abbastanza
lungo difficile ci vuole tempo anche per
questo non è facile lo facciamo anche
per evitare che ci siano quelli in
fraintendimenti sociali culturali che
spesso accadono nei progetti di
cooperazione allo sviluppo
lo facciamo partendo dal fatto che la
nostra figura per del cooperante
essenziale ma adesso la figura di
coordinamento esterno chi opera in
questa attività devono essere per forza
e principalmente da campesinos le
comunità indigene in questo momento sta
facendo michele che con grande dedizione
grande sforzo sta portando avanti il
progetto
da pendant soli insieme a in loco
insieme le comunità indigene lo fa di
coordinamento con noi collaborano una
ventina di persone più tante altre
persone chi si occupa della semina chi
si occupa degli vaio abbiamo vivai per
tutta l'area di riforestazione chi si
occupa del mantenimento che soffre la
disseminazione ovvero andare in giro per
tutelare di riforestazione a dire quali
sono nate practice per portare avanti le
piante che invece poi si occupa appunto
del mantenimento delle nostre delle
nostre piantina questo rappresenta però
anche un nodo principale
bene dei nostri progetti cioè il
coinvolgimento delle comunità perché
senza ovviamente non saremo in grado di
portare avanti i nostri progetti
perché loro sono poi i veri
finalizzatori di questo di cui di questo
motore chiamiamolo così perché partendo
da chi adotta la pianta praticamente il
ciclo si chiude con loro che sono i
finalizzatori ultimi di questo processo
e quindi non si vedono più costretti
o pagati per tagliarle piano non si
devono più costrette taglia le piante
per ricreare nuova terra vengono invece
in questo modo
remunerati per invece per piantare le
piante cerchiamo quindi abbiamo quindi
in questo modo riconvertito rigirato un
po la medaglia
lo facciamo appunto in questo sistema
come dicevamo prima anche gli
agroforestry quindi non soltanto piante
da foresta le piante appunto da foreste
vengono anche qualche volta consociate
con delle piante dovuto alimentare come
possono essere le luminose quindi diamo
comunque sempre la possibilità alle
comunità di portare avanti comunque
quello che il loro sostentamento anche
alimentare quindi cosa succede succede
che le queste comunità incominciano ad
avere un'entrata economica che deriva
dalla protezione ambientale
abbiamo dei dei casi per esempio molto
interessanti e che per noi rappresentano
un'ottima
cartina tornasole di quello che stiamo
facendo c'è gente che sta tornando dalle
città verso le aree rurali in cui stiamo
facendo i nostri progetti e di sotto
funzioni al contrario alcuni stanno
hanno più soldi appunto
per portare cibo casa riescono a mandare
i figli a scuola
tutto attraverso un processo appunto che
vede il cambiamento climatico lottato
attraverso l'impianto di queste di
questi giovani piantine che poi vengono
mantenute manie tarato per tre anni poi
per dieci anni vengono poi comunque
monitorate
come dicevo prima il convincimento che
cometa indigene popolazioni indigene
estremamente fondamentale tutto questo
si traduce con un termine tecnico che
sta alla base che ovvero che si dice che
il poncho dell'appropriazione tutti noi
ci saremmo sentiti ma abbiamo sentito
qualche volta sicuramente questo feeling
di sentirsi molto più coinvolta in un
progetto che ci prende a cuore
ed è proprio questo concetto e
l'appropriazione cioè sentirselo suo
proprio nostro questo ci dà anche la
garanzia che quando ce ne andremo e
succederà spero
una garanzia che le piante ammesso
rimarranno lì che le comunità indigene
andranno avanti con questo processo
perché anche tutti i vivai come vedete
nella foto rimarranno lì si andrà avanti
con questo processo e quindi noi siamo
in qualche modo sicuri che loro andranno
avanti
questo e mi chiede in un momento di
footing
come dicevo prima non ho
allora non ho voluto mostrarvi dati
numeri ho voluto raccontare una storia è
breve lo so avrei potuto raccontare ne
di più saputo di andare più nel
dettaglio
però due numeri concedetemi sono penso
che siano due numeri che vanno che
sottolineano un po quello che è il
nostro lavoro in questi anni
nel 2018
aveva piantato più o meno si fa per dire
3000 lve
quest'anno 2021 di alberi ne abbiamo
piantati 200 mila grazie a tutti e
quando lo vedete avrà sotto un albero
[Applauso]